we're assuming there's like powers at
work that want to keep things moving in
a certain direction however just to keep
things calm you fix this trial give this
guy whatever trial he thinks he's
getting if it's fair we're not acting
like people are above fixing a trial
right throw the book at them lock them
up for 15 years
everybody 20 years whatever people are
happy people are calm they're satiated
everything stays calm we are sacrificing
one cop who we don't think is a good cop
yeah but that's a thing like or even if
you're just like the powers be that's
just one human being that way the laws
are written he will probably get off I
think it's tricky I've heard both things
I think it's tricky with him
specifically because at a certain point
of time you can't put all the value on
the officers fear right because fear is
part of the job mm-hmm right my buddy
who my buddy Marco who was a marine and
was in Iraq right for years he said
something very interesting to me he was
like something happened in Iraq well not
something happened but basically the
idea of how America was gonna treat the
Iraq war changed while he was there and
basically the government said hey we're
gonna try to win over minds and hearts
so that is going to police not police
the others are gonna affect the way that
you treat people in Iraq and that's
actually gonna make your job way more
dangerous they said this to the Marines
so instead of when you're trying to win
a war you bust open the door shoot
whoever dies s casualties of a dice game
right the things change where was a we
want to win over Minds hearts you can't
go in guns blazing anymore
and they said to him your job is gonna
be more dangerous and that is the job
now and this is what you signed up for
and that's what you got to do
he said something interesting he goes
why he is zero tolerance for police
brutality is these if we could afford
that luxury to people in a foreign
country that we're technically at a war
with or in conflict with why can't we
afford that luxury to people who our own
citizens hmm right and I thought that
was super profound right if you're
busting in a door and you're not
shooting we're not talking about some
bin Laden we're talking about some other
so you're not shooting it might be a
[ __ ] terrorist you don't know
what they're doing but you're not
shooting you're holding on yeah
putting your life at risk and we're
talking about actual soldiers actual
soldiers at work you can't do that to a
random black guy that you see on the
street our own citizens who are supposed
to be innocent till proven guilty
innocent till proven guilty at war right
so he's he has zero tolerance for the
police brutality thing he said there is
a cultural thing maybe you can speak to
this because you've been a cop is do you
refer to it as a cop or a law you've
been part of law enforcement right is he
goes the crowd or credence of law
enforcement is no cop dies that's number
one
mm-hmm never let a cop die and he goes
that needs to be changed to protect the
community when protected community is
number one
it puts cops at more danger and you know
what we should pay them more for having
a more dangerous job but because of that
the way the policing will change now
you're not willing to bust off no matter
what because your number one goal is
protect the community at a high risk and
I think once you become the protective
community at a high risk guys you become
heroes and right now you were looked at
as the police state you looked at as the
enemy yeah and I'm really curious to
people in the UK like how they treat
cops maybe they don't like cops as much
but the fact that they don't got guns
and they're walking around with billy
clubs some lady with a billy club is
trying to stop someone that's some brave
[ __ ] and I'll be honest if it's just me
a lady in a billy club yeah you like
your odds becoming through like Adrian
Peterson but it's but it is a really
interesting way of looking at it right
yeah it's like if we could afford that
luxury to a foreign country that we're
at war with we got to be able to afford
it to citizens of our own country yeah
and to fight mean it's just crazy that
we don't I understand everybody scared
they want to go home then we need to
increase training and if you're afraid
maybe you're not built for that position
my buddy's been a situation where they
have trained fear out of people that's
what you have to do when you're busting
in a door of a compound you don't know
what the [ __ ] it is my buddy who's done
this in real life he's been in those
situations where he chose not to pull
the trigger hmm so it's not like this
can't
and lives that some might say we're less
valuable when you're at war with another
with another country that live is less
valuable than an American life yeah
people in America will also agree too
when they say like how can we do this to
our own people that's because you're
saying we are the most it's an American
citizen it's a more valuable life
somebody we're at war with casualties of
a dice game casualties of war there's no
collateral damage for lateral damage the
only people you don't let that are
really tragic or this friendly fire
that's the only innocent death that war
cares about no innocent kids died a
closeted doing business you friendly
fire that sucks you'll get a nice honor
when you get home but that's the only
thing that's like a tragedy does it is a
is a fundamental change and look I
understand how difficult it is to even
sit here and say that mm-hmm don't say
like I understand how difficult is
because when it's not my life that's on
the line you know like everybody who is
justifying the looting it's easy to say
that when it's not your place is being
looted their second your place is looted
all the sudden it's like now is getting
a little egregious it's it's it's so
easy to say these things when they're
not personally affecting you right just
like it's so easy to tell black people
hey relax when you're not black yeah
cause it ain't affecting you right it's
like hey this isn't the way to protest
and then black be like both look what is
no yes is the way that my putting a
square on Instagram my view on looting
is if I was black and people were like
looting isn't the answer and I'd be like
what is maybe like I don't know and
before they could say but maybe like I
call I'm over got a Louie Louie bag so
like from my trouble that's my answer
that's my you know as in traumatic
Instagram it's like the people's minds
we need to change like the real like
deep root of racists are all old right
yeah no no well if if you guys let me
finish making a [ __ ] the real people
whose minds you gotta change our people
and authority and power and then our
older right like some 20 year old kid
yeah maybe he don't care black people he
doesn't really have that much power
authority over you okay do you know I'm
said like yes there's gonna be racist
but like if you're both working together
at the job it's not like he can do that
much to oppress you right
what I'm saying is like these old
[ __ ] ain't on Instagram like
that do you think all these district
attorneys do you think all these month
now they have a social media team that
just post whatever they tell them
they've heard what the [ __ ] is going on
they're scrolling through seeing all
black and they're literally texting her
social media team like yo what's going
on his Instagram is Instagram down
it's an unaffected protest that's all
I'm trusting everybody understands
breaking [ __ ] yeah so I would agree with
you it's probably a uneffective protest
but things that happen on social media
do get back to the higher-ups that
aren't on so yeah yeah a lot of times
like people like Shaun King
white or black man that he is yeah it
will help affect change because he
applies pressure to the higher-ups oh no
doubt [ __ ] damn you got to do something
about this because everybody's
complaining and no duh yeah there's no
doubt there's no doubt about that you
are it's a what I think this isn't this
started with in the music industry I
think it's a lot of like white people
new music going to felt guilty and they
didn't know what to do and they have no
[ __ ] clue what to do but they
couldn't sit around making money off
black but you also gotta look proactive
well yeah because you're making money
all black people so you're like I need
to show support but how do I show
support I can't go break [ __ ] right cuz
all the [ __ ] that's being broken is mine
yeah like you know if white people you
really want to support the looting just
break your own window literally walk
outside your door
bust your door and be like I got y'all
it's something to it sound idea I don't
know I I'm not saying go do that but I
under how do I understand it it's like
nah we all know the looting is raw don't
you think looting is wrong and breaking
[ __ ] is yeah I wouldn't personally do it
but I'm not knocking anybody who's doing
it because I'm just as angry and
frustrated that [ __ ] hasn't changed I'm
just not gonna resort to looting to
express that anger and that's it that's
the sorry to interrupt but like
everybody even agrees on looting like if
everybody agrees everybody agrees on
every aspect of this we've never been so
unified in the most divisive time in our
country outside of civil war we have
never been so unified on one issue and
so destructive
how is that possible
so unique right because peaceful
protests and I'm I'm never gonna loot
I'm a [ __ ] but peaceful protests
weren't doing anything so at a certain
point you just have to make noise to get
the other side to be like okay this is
too much let's do something because
there has been peaceful protests and
nobody gave a [ __ ] ya know it's
interesting
Trayvon everybody took the picture with
their hoodie up I am Trayvon yay
alright mo there will be another yeah I
mean sometimes you gotta [ __ ] [ __ ] up t
it's like a kid pitching a fit I see
parents always bent bend to the whim of
their kid when they're pitching a fit
and I'm like I want you ignore that
because that's what gets attention
[Applause]